[Music]
General Anderson and Natalia sokolova's
New Alliance has led to the true sons
being embedded into the Black Tusk they
have been helping Sokolova grow her
Fleet of hovercrafts in DC there are
concerns that this could lead to
increased mortar strike activity
division agents have been tasked with
taking down a new team formed through
this new alliance they are heavily armed
and know exactly where to attack in
order to do the maximum amount of damage
[Music]
thank you
Charles chunks Crawford had a background
in the Navy as an ENT or Electronics
technician nuclear power before being
recruited by the Black Tusk
he was highly skilled at tending to
reactors on submarines and preferred
deep sea over the surface he was known
as chunks when he first entered the Navy
because of his severe seasickness he
discovered that he could handle
Subterranean life better than life on a
Surface ship and asked to be transferred
to the nukes
considered as the Navy's best and
brightest nukes are known for being a
bit eccentric with some struggling to
handle the stress and demands of the job
but chunks embraced this position and
saw himself as the ideal nuke
however beneath his seemingly harmless
nickname an impressive technical skills
looked a disturbing and unsettling
personality
chunks was known to have control issues
and an insatiable desire for power and
control over others
the sadistic Tendencies were evident and
as disregard for value of human life he
would often take pleasure in
manipulating and dominating his
subordinates treating them like mere
tools to be used for his own benefit in
his mind the ends always Justified the
means no matter how many lives were
sacrificed in the process
his Twisted Behavior made him a feared
and respected member of the Black Tusk
his superiors appreciated his unwavering
loyalty and willingness to carry out
orders without question
chunks may have been a master attending
to reactors but his true Talent Lena's
ability to manipulate and control those
around him
everything's in working order right
morale is low main complaint the food
we've got plenty of MREs but all we got
are MREs the crew is getting enough to
eat but it's not enjoyable you want me
to find you a chef that's excessive but
if we could get some fresh food it would
go a long way towards boosting morale
you want salads yes there are plenty of
wild edibles by the river or we could
just take the campus in time
for now
if you want a salad go forage one
how's morale great your team enjoying
foraging not exactly
I told you to leave the campus alone we
did I don't need you drawing unwanted
attention before we're ready we found a
small community North of the city any
agent no all civilians some kind of
prepper or Homestead community
they were isolated and well hidden not
that well hidden we spotted three of
them fishing and tracked them back to
Camp with a drone occupy or Raid
occupy left a couple of guards to keep
their operation going
we can rely on weekly Harvest from the
farm for the troops in DC and they've
already put up a fair amount for winter
do you need replacements for the guards
not yet but we couldn't use transpo if
you want to supply the other teams
is it true is what true what people are
saying about St Louis
I have no idea what you're talking about
well it is there was an attack you're
going to have to be more specific
that's some Rogue agents working
together
what would the outcast be doing in St
Louis you tell me you're acting paranoid
do we need to worry about radiation
poisoning from St Louis from Outcast no
are you sure yes if you're really
worried get a geiger counter where am I
supposed to get one of those Department
of interior Parks and Recreation your
prepper group Best Buy Museum the power
plant pick your poison
[Music]
on first lesson these comps may not seem
very significant but the last one in
particular is actually referencing
events that played out in the division
recruited novel
confirming that the game is playing out
alongside the novels and it's quite cool
to see the Crossovers here
to give some background Rowan was a
former division agent turned Rogue and
was once a part of the sale of agents
that the novel follows
Rowan's family had been killed following
the outbreak like so many others
but she was later believed that the true
Sons were responsible due to the events
that played out on Roosevelt Island
when in reality this was a lie told to
her by the cell leader
her family were sent into a quarantine
but it wasn't the jtf or the true sons
who killed them
after the outcasts took over and seized
control of the camp the division
launched a strike and her family was
caught in the crossfire and killed
the division killed a family of an agent
and that was hidden from her
she would go on to weaponize a sample of
the green poison and then release it
into the water supply of an encampment
of true Sons
the true Sons were decimated but not
before they had spread it to three
nearby civilian communities
hundreds of people died
but Rowan would then find out the truth
of what actually happened to her family
and she to Trail hard
two division agents were dispatched to
bring her in for questioning
she killed both and then disappeared
erections drew the attention of the
outcasts they approved of the measures
and given that they are now leaderless
she obviously offered them something in
return for their help
the attack in St Louis happened while
the cell was in pursuit of Rowan who was
on her way to attack one of the shd
calls
there were explosions and the buildings
around them started to crumble and this
is where Isaac announced warning
radiation detected the outcasts were
using dirty bombs
now it makes sense that chunks are so
concerned about this being a former Navy
nuclear technician is more than well
aware of the dangers of radiation
I don't think the story has caught up
with what happened at the end of
recruited so I won't talk about that
anymore in this video however given
circle of his response to this there
could be more crossovers to come
regarding outcasts and I'm going to
speculate more on this in another video
soon
the story of chunks demise began with a
tip received by the division agents
according to their Intel chunks was
hiding somewhere within the West Potomac
Park of Washington DC
the Agents set out to take down the
Black Tusk outposts one by one until
they found themselves at the Lincoln
Memorial
the black task had fortified the area
heavily and it seemed like a daunting
task for the agents to get through but
they were determined to stop chunks and
slowly but surely they made their way
through the facility
despite facing numerous enemies
including heavily armed guards and
warhounds the agents were Relentless in
their Pursuit
finally they came face to face with
their target
chunks appeared to be caught off guard
and didn't put up much resistance
the agent swiftly cleared out his
bodyguards and in no time chunks was
eliminated
firstly let's talk about the castle
sediment it has been years since the
settlement was first attacked by the
true Sons using a weaponized version of
dc-62 but to be fair in game it's only
been a few months
there have been rumors around the castle
sediment but I haven't paid much
attention as there wasn't anything
official to back it up
my first thoughts when we were directed
there in game there is more to the story
we don't need another settlement we've
been fine without it so far however it
does paint the picture that perhaps the
jtf and civilians are doing a little
better in DC than we've been led to
believe up until now I've always felt
the existing settlements and even the
White House would barely holding on at
this point but if they are able to
divert this much Manpower and other
resources perhaps things aren't as Grim
as they've seemed of the last few months
in game
however like I just said I believe there
is more to the settlement
when running around and checking out the
compound you can see a lot of work going
on comms being set up electricity
foundations for buildings farming spots
plus a number of jtf who look like
they're just over this [__] and probably
should have just called in sick
the underground area seems to have been
locked off but there is another way down
there heading onto the street you can
find this entranceway that leads you
directly under the settlement there are
no guards or anything but there are
doors to be opened it still works in the
same way as the settlement as in you
cannot use weapons Etc except there
really is nothing down there I've been
through it a number of times and there's
nothing except for a few unmarked
civilians
but back up in the main section you can
find a crafting table and a
recalibration station this immediately
struck me as odd as there are only so
many locations that have this and the
other two DC settlements certainly don't
from everything I'm seeing here the area
feels incomplete not just because
they're currently rebuilding the place
but that there is far more planned for
the area in the near future
I feel like a lot of the assets here are
just placeholders for the next few
months where eventually this place will
be a far greater significance to the
story and I'll expand on this idea
further a little later in the video
[Music]
when first jumping into season 11 we
meet Manny for the usual Target brief
but then we were immediately sent to the
castle to meet Wally
there has been an increase of Hunter
drone activity in DC and she has managed
to hack into a couple of them revealing
some Intel
now this is obviously the way that the
main comms are going to be acquired this
season but it's good to hear the hunters
are still being featured in the story
anyway the first two comms we've
received through the sentel follows a
similar path of the Intel received in
the chunks Manhunt
got proud of DC I spoke with Cal
yesterday and he has assured me that the
rumors are just rumors the report out of
St Louis a complete fabrication nothing
to worry about
even if it were true it's an anomaly not
a trend
nothing for you to worry about what
about supplies going through the area we
have alternate routes
there is no danger of shortages if
that's what you're worried about hey you
talk to chunks I have
I assure you there are no shortages and
we have more than enough to sustain us
we are in this for the Long Haul
the first one covers something I
discussed in the chunks Manhunt video
I'll have a link to this in the top
right but essentially Stoke pipe is
asking if these rumors are true based on
the recruited novel they are 100 True
yet for some reason Natalia or perhaps
McManus is denying it
merely
a hypothetical question okay
hypothetically
what would happen to a mortar operator
if they were to use a launcher that had
previously housed a dirty bomb Too Many
Factors to consider
exposure time amount of radioactive
material amount of transfer
kind of particulate it wouldn't be
instantly fatal of course not
we're exposed to radiation every day by
the time you're showing symptoms of
radiation poisoning it's generally too
late thank you chunks
why are you asking no reason
I just like to be prepared for all
scenarios
if you're worried about exposure at the
plant you should start taking iodine to
protect your thyroid that's a very
useful information
this to me shows that Natalya doesn't
believe what McManus is saying to her
about the events in St Louis
or maybe her and McManus are just trying
to cover this up from their crew for
some reason
what's more interesting about this piece
of Intel is what chunks said at the end
there about taking iodine to help
protect the thyroid
the reason this is interesting is
because of something that Wally said
after completing the chunks Manhunt
guess we should start looking for
natural sources of iodine just in case
should probably start eating more fish
and seaweed from Mario's exhibits at the
aquarium
took me a few seconds to click when I
first heard this to begin with I thought
this was an unknown name that would
become more important over the course of
this Manhunt as they don't tend to give
names of characters unless there is some
sort of significance to this story going
forward
but some of you may remember this name
come up in one of the classified
assignments that came out in year one
this particular one was called Central
Aquarium
you could be forgiven for forgetting
what this was all about and it certainly
had me looking through the others for a
bit of a refresher but long story short
we were there to rescue Mari Singh and a
number of other civilians at the
aquarium that was being taken over by
hyenas but the rescue wasn't really the
significant part
I'm not going to play all of the comms
as this could be a standalone video on
its own but the Intel from this
assignment showed the interaction
between Mari and her colleagues they
were short on supplies and worried about
what they were going to do going forward
when it came to feeding the animals
under their care
everything was locked down they weren't
able to get trucks in and they couldn't
simply take the animals away
they contemplated feeding the smaller
fish to the large ones in mammals but
this would only be a temporary solution
Murray eventually acknowledged that the
city is full of hungry people and that
food is running out perhaps the best
solution was to honor the animals and
provide them as food for the hungry
population rather than just let the
animals starve to death
but it wasn't just all about killing off
the larger animals and feeding them to
the people
the aquarium has a sustainable fishing
program they have the facilities to
provide a communal fishery a source of
food for the starving civilians
this was certainly a big deal at the
time a sustainable source of food but
with everything else going on in year
one it was easy to have forgotten this
however with the threat of radiation
along with the growing need for food The
Mention Of Maori and her fishery is no
coincidence
she and her aquarium are something that
we're gonna have to fight for going
forward
I don't usually do this but I'm going to
play the trailer and discuss what I
think could be important going forward
we got used to winning
to defeating our enemies
or turning them to our cause Schaefer is
still in a coma so I don't believe we'll
be seeing anything from him this season
I could be wrong here who may make an
appearance later but I don't think this
will be the case this Manhunt
[Music]
but now they have their own Alliance
led by Sokolova
and if the Mastermind of the Black Tusk
is coming to Washington
it will be to eliminate the division
that's why she needs stovepipe
they don't care about the cost this
agent Watch scene is something I pointed
out on Twitter and Instagram it shows
that there are more than just trophies
for the hunters that they are drawing
Intel from them but what they already
seem to know everything about each agent
especially given that Kelvin McManus as
the Secretary of Homeland Security has
had all of this information around the
division agents so what information are
they Gathering somewhat off topic I'm
seriously considering setting up my
recording studio like this I feel it
would really put me in the zone
only who wins and finally we have the
White House going dark
to me at least this symbolizes an attack
or at the very least the DC base of
operations is being targeted and brought
to its knees
maybe this is the end of Schaefer due to
the power supply being cut I don't think
so though or at least I hope not there
is a reason they've kept him alive in
the story for this long
but I think this could be the answer to
all of my questions around the castle
sediment it's probably a bit of a
stretch but that's never held me back
before I think the White House is
finally going to come under attack I've
been questioning this for quite a while
the black tusks certainly have the
overwhelming Manpower and equipment to
do this up until the castle sediment
being restored the White House appears
to have been run by a skeleton crew as
the jtf numbers have dropped so low
perhaps them sending so many people to
rebuilding the castle sentiment is the
reason it's finally being attacked
I don't know but whatever happens I
think the castle is going to be our new
base of operations even if just
temporarily while recapturing the White
House
Lieutenant Martin bantam's background as
a U.S army drone operator gave him a
unique perspective on warfare
he was able to control unmanned aerial
vehicles and used them to Target enemy
combatants without ever setting foot on
the battlefield
however as time went on Bantam would
become desensitized to the violence he
was causing from afar as he transitioned
to become a member of the true Sons
Bantam continued to use his skills to
Target enemies from a safe distance
however his beliefs about responsibility
began to morph into a twisted
justification for his actions Bantam
convinced himself that he was not
responsible for the deaths caused by his
drone strikes as long as he did not
physically see blood on his hands
he was able to ignore the fact that his
actions were causing real-life
consequences for other human beings
this cognitive disconnect allowed him to
continue his violent Behavior without
any remorse
it's clear that bantam's mindset is a
dangerous one
by disconnecting himself from the
reality of the situation and the harm
he's causing he's able to justify his
violent actions and become a danger to
those around him
Lieutenant Martian Bantam is a
cautionary tale about the dangers of
Detachment and warfare and how it can
lead to dangerous beliefs and behaviors
prior to the operation Bantam expressed
his doubts about collaborating with the
Black Tusk he had always been a loyal
true son but the recent alliance with
the Black Tusk had made him uneasy he
knew that their ultimate goal was to
gain control of the capital and Rule it
with a nine fist
but he wasn't sure that their method was
something that he was able to be a part
of
guns and black tasks are set up on the
Potomac and ready to deploy General
thank you Bantam hold tight what are we
waiting for I wish I could tell you but
my pay grade or above yours too sir it's
neat to know but do you know I know
enough
are you sure about these people sir I'm
sure that if we want to win this war
Lieutenant we need allies
with these allies do you have enough
food yes do you have housing and clean
clothes yes do you have enough weapons
and medical supplies yes do you have
enough mortars enough to level the city
so do you feel like you have the tools
and resources at your disposal to win
this war absolutely how do you feel
about our new allies now better General
good hold tight and wait for orders
he was torn between his loyalty to the
true sons and the Practical benefits of
working with the Black Tusk but
ultimately he knew that the true Sons
couldn't have kept going in the way that
they were their resources were dwindling
and this situation was becoming
increasingly dire
the true Sons were in disparate need of
a game changer and this could be it
the Recon streets are
Castle
the castle settlement yes sir what about
the dc-62
extensive decontamination efforts have
been made since Captain Wilson's attack
looks like they're getting ready to
reopen the settlement oh
oh well good for them while he's been
seen at the castle as well makes sense
they were always close no news on the
other Target Natalia I'd like to hear
that from you do you mind giving her a
call there's nothing to tell well she'd
like to hear it from you I'd rather not
why not sure she's scared the [__] out
of me
any updates no ma'am eyes on the Target
no ma'am do we at least have
confirmation that he's still on site no
ma'am do we have anything we have
footage of him being brought back to the
White House after Coney Island he's
badly injured no aerial footage since is
he still alive no way to confirm at this
time if he's alive they they never let
him outside
's aerial drones have shown what is
happening at the castle sediment and the
huge efforts going into rebuilding it
but also the movements going both in and
out of the White House
they are now very aware of Captain
Lewis's involvement with the castle
being rebuilt as well as Wally
they are also now aware that Barton
Schaefer was taken to the White House
but they have no idea if he's still
alive or not
I wonder if my suspicions are correct
about the White House coming under
attack but the potential for Schaefer to
be alive with all the secrets he holds
be the reason they attack
if we want to retrofit more mortars I'm
gonna need more dc-62 thank you for
telling me Lieutenant General does that
mean you're going to send more dc-62
yeah at this point contamination threats
may not be in our best interests visible
contamination what are you implying
rumors about radiation sir oh rumors
what rumors about the plant no St Louis
what about St Louis you really don't
know do you excuse me there's nothing to
know I can't tell if you're full of [__]
or your new friend is teaching you to be
a fantastic [__] liar watch your tone
Lieutenant I don't give a [__] about my
tone I want to know if I need to worry
about radiation poisoning sir
this calms continues the rumors that
were started in the chunks Manhunt and
while we know that the attack on St
Louis aren't just rumors I'm beginning
to think that this isn't just a nice
crossover to the novels
this is going to feature more heavily
going forward but I really can't put my
finger on how at this point dirty bombs
radiation how would this assist either
side going forward if these were brought
to DC or New York
or maybe that's the point perhaps those
crazy bastards known as the outcasts are
going to be the reason for the Black
Tusk and the division to call a truce
for a little while but if that was the
case wise McManus Circle over and maybe
Anderson trying to hide it from everyone
[Music]
following the successful elimination of
their first Target chunks division
agents quickly received Intel on
Lieutenant Martian bantam's whereabouts
it was revealed that he was actively
operating within the Foggy Bottom
District of Washington DC which prompted
agents to launch a full-scale operation
to take down the true Sun outposts in
the area
with each Outpost that was taken down
the agents gathered more information
about bantam's location which eventually
LED them to the heavily defended
compound of the Potomac Event Center
the true Sons were abundant in Supply
and it was clear that this was going to
be a challenging mission
despite the odds the division agents
were well prepared and had the necessary
equipment to take on the heavily
Fortified Compound
the white death with its overpowered
Talent determined proved to be a game
changer and it felt more like target
practice than a national battle
as agents made their way through the
compound they eventually came face to
face with Bantam himself
in an uncharacteristic move Bantam
decided to engage in the fight himself
showing a level of Courage that was
unexpected from someone who had
previously hidden behind a screen
however his efforts were no match for
the well-trained division agents
with one swift Bullet to the face
Phantom was taken out of commission
it's unclear whether he would have put
up much of a resistance if he hadn't
engaged in the fight but the agents were
relieved to have completed their mission
successfully
the elimination of Bantam would bring
the one step closer to tracking down
their main target
stovepipe
Mort curse Kellogg's life took a turn
for the worse when he developed a
serious gambling problem he found
himself in debt to Loan Sharks before he
even graduated from high school and the
debts only grew larger as time went on
eventually he realized that he needed to
do something drastic to get out of debt
and avoid his collectors so he enlisted
in the army
he was deployed to the dagger complex in
darmstadt Germany where he quickly
became known for his logistical
expertise he had a natural talent for
managing suppliers and his superiors
took notice however cursed was never
able to shake his gambling habit even in
Germany he continued to gamble on Sports
and other events often putting himself
further into debt
when the green poison was released
Hearst was on a weekend trip to
Copenhagen in Malmo where he bought a
Euro jackpot lottery ticket he played
his lucky numbers and forgot about the
ticket until the drawing the following
Friday but his amazement all of his
numbers came up but his excitement was
short-lived as he learned about the
viral outbreak that was rapidly
spreading across the globe
curse luck seemed to have run out but
fate had other plans
he would eventually join the Black Tusk
and become one of the highest ranking
Logistics officers
his expertise in managing supplies and
resources made him invaluable to the
organization and he quickly Rose through
the ranks
his gambling habit may have put him in
debt but it also gave him a natural
talent for taking calculated risks
something that would serve him well in
this new position
as a member of the Black Tusk Hearst was
instrumental in many of their operations
using his expertise to help the
organization acquire the resources they
needed to accomplish their goals
despite his past he had become a
respected and trusted member of the
group and his loyalty to the cause was
never in question
um you want me to reach out to Bantam or
Kaplan Kaplan Phantom seems nervous
huh a lot of these true Sons defected
they did
looks like they weren't as loyal to
Anderson as he thought
the trouble with following a charismatic
leader when you lose the leader you lose
your following agreed best part of
working for a faceless organization
you're behold to a power structure not a
narcissist
can't tell if you're being sarcastic no
sarcasm I signed on for the big picture
Safety and Security
you know me so well I do
and that's why I think you're the right
person to reach out to Kaplan we need to
weed out potential traders in our midst
you worried she's a traitor no
I think she's got the right access
psychology and skill set to spot them
Natalia is looking for any more
potential traitors within the true Sons
it believes Kaplan could be the one to
find them this Khan's piece also shows
the sort of loyalty Hearst has with
Natalya and the Black Tusk
no updates on Schaefer thank you
just wanted to confirm bantam's report
is it going to be a problem I don't
think so
he's too afraid of me to betray me I
don't know how anyone can be afraid of
you that's because you've never been on
the receiving end of my wrath cursed
that's true you have saved my life on
more than one occasion have you found
anything only thing a note I've seen
some specialized medical equipment going
in and out of the White House could be
for Schaefer could be nothing no way to
town without infiltrating the White
House that's a suicide mission
stick to Recon for now
confirmation that someone's in a coma
but you can't confirm it is Schaefer
that's unfortunately correct Source we
apprehended one of the cooks and how
does that confirm a coma patient they
were instructed to make meals for tube
feeding and maintain feed line
sanitation but they never installed the
line or saw the patient
that's correct said that there was
restricted access to his room who has
clearance
[Applause]
Kelso Dr ummers and our old friend
well he sure fell into favor quickly is
there an opportunity there perhaps
he's been turned before
men like that
aren't the most loyal
[Music]
Captain Lewis has shifted loyalties
twice in the past we abandoned the jtf
true sons and then once again more
recently when he teamed up with the
division Natalia sees this as a
potential opportunity
they still haven't confirmed that
Schaefer is in there but they're
certainly getting close
it's seeming more and more likely that
if this attack on the White House does
happen that Schaefer is going to be the
reason for it Natalia knows that he has
too much Intel to give if he was to ever
wake up
are you worried about radiation
you've been talking to chunks haven't
you no stove paint just take your iodine
and calm down you don't think the rumors
are true about St Louis yeah I think
anytime people tell you a rumor is just
a rumor they're trying to cover
something up so yeah I think the rumors
are true
[__] don't worry about St Louis worry
about Fairview why
you've seen the way they handle the
nuclear waste
no no they would have told us
brother I think your helmet's on too
tight
I'm still not sure how the events in St
Louis would tie into the story yet I
don't see us hitting over there but
maybe it'll have something to do with
the future conflicts against the
outcasts
however what I find more interesting is
the reference to Fairview power plant
not just from cursed but also from Wally
right after receiving these comms
ever since we lost major Castillo that
place has gone to [__] I get why he had
to take him out that man's grief drove
him to some really dark places
when Majors Castillo was taken out there
wasn't really anyone to look after the
plant yes he trained to fuel the crew
Sons to keep things running but this was
never going to be adequate in the long
term
Phantom's training is a nuke more than
justifies his concerns however he's now
gone too
Natalia is a smart lady Julie she is
aware of what's Happening Here and what
is she planning
forget dc-62 or even the green poison
radiation and dirty bombs could soon be
the problem and as far as I'm aware I
don't think the division has anyone
qualified to fix it so we can't exactly
storm the area
as the division agents received Intel on
what cursed's Kellogg's whereabouts they
quickly mobilized and headed towards
Constitution Hall where the black task
was conducting their operations the team
had to move cautiously and strategically
taking down various outposts one by one
throughout the district to ensure their
cover wasn't blown
once they cleared the outposts the
agents discovered the cursed had moved
to Tidal Basin a heavily Fortified Area
controlled by the Black Tusk
team had their work cut out for them but
they were determined to take down the
enemy and put an end to their plans
they encountered Fierce resistance as
they made their way through the area but
their extensive training and Superior
Equipment proved to be too much
eventually cursed would make his
presence known and approach the agents
exceptionally slowly
at this point it's hard not to feel
sorry for Mort curse Kellogg not only
did he have a gambling addiction that
would eventually result in him being
placed into this very position the
agents are facing right now but he would
also be trolled by the Black Tusk who
would put him in the hilariously clunky
armor with a belt-fit minigun that the
agents were more than familiar with by
now
after clearing his Entourage the agent
spent a little bit of time playing with
their prey until they eventually decided
to show him how it was done by pulling
out their own minigun and Blasting holes
straight through his armor
foreign
ification confirmed Lord cursed Kellogg
status deceased
Beatrice Auntie Kaplan with a
deceptively sweet and unassuming
presence up as a dark and dangerous side
that lurks beneath the surface
mocking the conventional expectations of
society Kaplan having no desire to have
children would often joke about a future
as an eccentric old cat lady
during basic training at the first
target practice session a new recruit
playfully gave her the name Auntie
shortly after this new recruit as well
as Kaplan would be involved in what she
called a reloading accident that would
ultimately claim the recruit's life
any doubts of whether the incident was
actually an accident would be cleared up
after she shamelessly seized the
opportunity to wield her Newfound infamy
insisting that everyone a dresser is
Auntie she sought to instill a sense of
fear and respect from those around her
Auntie showed no guilt or remorse for
her actions and instead used it as a
stark reminder of the ever-present
danger and mortality that haunted their
lives of their crosster but also to
solidify her position of power and
dominance within the ranks
when she heard news about the true Sons
aligning themselves with a Black Tusk
she was most excited about the fact that
she would no longer go by the name hitty
officer Kaplan and instead have people
continue to refer to her as auntie
in awaiting orders General thank you
Kaplan Auntie right thank you Auntie no
problem General
about those orders continue to do
perimeters sweeps of all known division
control location s and look for any weak
spots or opportunities and if I find any
you want me to move in or report back
deserve a report for now
Alia has a plan and we need to support
border vision
do we get to know what that vision is
eventually eventually when the time is
right we still don't know who we can
trust this Alliance is too new and Lewis
has unfortunately brought too many
people to his side
you worried about bantam should I be
well is he still insisting you call him
Lieutenant Phantom yes it's like
switching teams just because you put on
the uniform it doesn't make you a part
of the team and if you won't even put on
the uniform how much do you really want
to be on the new team right
good point auntie
permission to go off base why I want to
meet cursed in person
permission denied I just need two hours
we can find a neutral place to meet why
do you want to meet him he reached out
wants me to help root out the rest of
the rats and Traders we're talking about
Bantam again no
Phantoms too chicken [__] to do anything
he'll die before he grows the balls to
defy orders I don't know about that he's
harmless
I mean unless you order him to kill
people then he's actually pretty good at
his job
but he's not one to get original ideas
and if a bad actor gets in his ear oh
well then yeah he can be easily
manipulated
you want me to keep tabs on him just in
case that might not be a bad idea
you know you're watching
that's the only way I know how to watch
permission denied why
worried I'll draw too much attention
need to stay on Mission worried I'll get
distracted or something who knows
that's too bad I was really looking
forward to meeting you me too is it true
you were stationed in Germany when this
all went down
it is you ever see combat before this
I've been deployed what's your number
before this
um
20 or 30 after 50 I stopped counting
really yeah too hard to keep track not
for me what's your number 372.
were you deployed before this
nope
went through basic and joined the guard
they never got to see any real action
until the jtf was activated
372 kills this year
it's impressive 371.
actually
these columns are just a continuation of
the conversations cursed was having with
Natalia she has asked kurz to get in
touch with Auntie and use her to help
weed out the traitors
these are all showing that Natalia
doesn't hold the true sons in
particularly high regard especially
after Captain Lewis jumped ship with a
large group of the true Sons
it also shows that Natalia continues to
have absolutely no confidence in General
Anderson he has been left completely in
the dark and now has her men going
around him in order to discuss plans
with certain true Sons
I know about the dirty bombs what about
them your little experiment here someone
stole it and used it in St Louis what
experiment the goddamn dirty bombs
Natalya those pipe I have never approved
experimental dirty bombs perhaps the
isolation is getting to you
you're full of [__] Natalya I do not
appreciate your tone I don't give a [__]
get me out of here I'm done finish
setting up the base at Coney Island and
I'll send a relief team to finish her
mission in New York
we can sort out this confusion when you
get back to base
through this interaction we learn of the
location of stovepipe pony Island it
sounds like he is setting up a base for
an attack on New York City with all of
these past comms this season it appears
Natalia could be planning to use dirty
bombs on the city obviously stovepipe
isn't particularly happy about this and
chooses to call her out and who can
blame him everything we've heard has led
us to similar suspicions
one thing is for certain though the
disrespect he's shown there is no way
Natalia will let that slide
Auntie's downfall started with a tip
that reached the division agents
revealing her presence in Washington
DC's West End district with this
information in hand the agents embarked
on a mission to dismantle the true Sun
outposts progressing through until they
eventually find out that Auntie was
located on Roosevelt Island
the island stood as a daunting challenge
for the determined agents but undeterred
by the overwhelming odds they pressed
forward navigating the treacherous
landscape of the compound
the area had been heavily fortified by
the true Sons presenting a formidable
challenge for the agents to overcome but
step by step they would push through and
eventually close them on Auntie however
in typical division agent fashion they
would shoot first and ask questions
later
they actually didn't get a visual
confirmation on the target before
one-shotting something through some
foliage
they would have to run to the other side
of the map to confirm it was her and
with this target down an all-available
Intel gathered the agents would be able
to move on to the main target stovepipe
though I hope her sister doesn't seek
revenge I don't think that fight would
go down in quite the same way
Zachary stovepipe BT possessed a unique
and dangerous fascination with
explosives that would eventually shape
his path in unexpected ways
trained as an explosive Ordnance
disposal Specialist or EOD he initially
immersed himself in the study of
demolitions out of sheer passion
while his primary Duty was to neutralize
explosive threats stovepipe Sensational
curiosity led him down a dark path
as he delved deeper into his field
stovepipe's obsession with the
destructive power of explosives grew he
meticulously collected schematics
prototypes and classified information on
increasingly unstable improvised
explosive devices
he pushed the boundaries of his
knowledge exploring the most hazardous
and volatile designs all in the pursuit
of a fascination with watching the world
burn
surprisingly stovepipe's unorthodox
collection didn't lead to the expected
consequences instead of facing a court
martial for his dangerous hobby his
commanding officer recognized the
potential value of his expertise and
connections
this recognition ultimately sparked an
unexpected turn of events when the Black
task took notice of stowpipe's unique
skills and approached him with an
intriguing proposition
the Black Tusk sorn stovepipe a person
who shared their desire to exploit chaos
for their own game
they recognized his uncanny ability to
navigate the world of destructive
technology and the potential for him to
come a valuable asset in their
operations
drawn to the Allure of power stovepipe
accepted the invitation to join the
ranks of the Black Tusk
it was within this organization that his
expertise and explosives would find its
true purpose
in position inventory assessment
complete how are we looking on mortars
even with the two new teams we have more
than enough to maintain control of the
shipping lanes that's very good
let me know if we need to pull in
additional resources we'll do but
honestly this feels like Overkill to
secure the river better to Overkill than
be killed
funny you need anything else from me not
at this time stovepipe can't you just
call me Zach wouldn't be professional
stovepipe I hate that nickname most
people hate their nicknames you didn't
make Faith take a nickname say it was
special
and what am I reliable
presumably on Coney Island Stoke pipe
updates Natalia on the status of the
setup including the mortar launchers
that they'll be using to keep hold of
the river
why do you want to know that
professional curiosity no there is no
way to use dirty bombs and RM water
launchers without contaminating the
launcher that's what I thought I just
wanted confirmation I don't like this
hypothetical question it's just a
question it's a [__] up question
that's the world is this about St Louis
what do you know about St Louis
dirty bomb attack on a convoy rumors
conjecture and fear-mongering to keep
people from moving through the Midwest
you sure letting me sort through the
propaganda you just keep digging through
that Intel and see if there's anything
we can use
you got it boss
why humor me there is no safe way to
house this [__] long term short term do
you care if people die of course
then concrete lead concrete and Lead
line crates that no one touches without
full radioactive protection at all times
with decontamination showers after then
deconstruct destroy and bury the
launchers after use
it doesn't make sense
the risk isn't worth it unless you want
people to die of radiation poisoning
thank you stealth pipe seriously
is this about St Louis was that us it
was not us so it's true
St Louis happened of course it happened
why did you lie to me you didn't need to
know
these columns are obviously from before
stovepipes Outburst in the columns that
we heard while hunting down Auntie he
brings up Saint Louis twice and Natalia
even admits to lying about the events
that happened there this on top of
Natalya's questions about radiation in
dirty bombs he is right to be nervous
if this is what Natalia is planning
agents realize they need to close in on
his position and fast
when agents arrived on the island it was
quiet too quiet
in fact there were no enemies at all and
senses indicate that the stovepipe
hasn't moved since the agents arrived
eventually they would catch up to
stovepipe except someone had beat them
to it
he was already dead
it was a trap
from the Black Tusk coppercraft in the
distance a swarm of drones as well as a
couple of marauder-class quadcopters
were launched on the agent's position
agents attempt to reach the extraction
point but wave after wave of drones mini
tanks warhounds automated turrets and a
heap of emps are blocking their way
they managed to quickly push through but
before Torres is able to pick them up
there is one small enemy that needs to
be removed
but don't let the name fool you that
[__] is Satan's hellhound and
here I go a little off story and break
the immersion my wife uh Slash manager
told me I should probably remove this
part because it's a little bit off brand
but I promised a few of you that I
wouldn't hold back on my emotions and
true feelings about this part of the
mission so the following are actual
clips of my first few playthroughs let's
just call this an intermission but feel
free to skip forward a minute or so to
continue the story just [__] off but for
[__] sake avocado
[Music]
why
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
the problem you can jump on for a few
minutes just to finish off the
maintenance won't take long yeah man
give me a moment why does he keep
chasing me what the [__] is wrong with
this damn thing you got this he's
actually not so bad when you're at Big
Chase bro are you dead again yeah um
yeah yeah I am
the fact that his name is Sparkles only
makes it that much worse
after the agents managed to put a stop
to the final Target on Coney Island
comfortably definitely without getting
close to rage quitting several times
Torres was about to come in and extract
them however this is when the true depth
of this situation really came to light
while the agents have been playing at
the dog park the Black Tusk have
attacked the White House
it all makes sense now stovepipe and the
whole attack on Coney Island was just a
distraction
Sokolova was waiting until the agents
were off-site before taking down the
network and then attacking the White
House
the only reason they are able to
communicate and use skills now is
because of Wally's mobile shd server
fighting through the outskirts agents
make their way through the black task
forces to meet up with Kelso at the
White House
as the agents make it to the gates they
watch as several Black Tusk helicopters
depart with one of them carrying the
perfusion bioreactor
at the compound they come across a
Razorback that has been set up on the
White House lawn
after a surprisingly short encounter
given what has been experienced through
this Manhunt so far agents would make
their way through to the White House
alongside Alani Kelso
what they found was a massacre
while all of the black tasks had cleared
out from the compound the agents were
left with the Stark reality of what had
just occurred
along with many others Captain Lewis had
given his life to protect the jtf in the
base of operations
through Echoes on site the agents were
able to see that Lewis had made the
ultimate sacrifice in order to give many
the time to escape and hide with
Schaefer
while Lewis was comfortably holding his
own it would seem that one of Natalia's
Hunters was able to sneak up on him and
take him down by surprise
Kelso and agent Sanders someone we
haven't seen since the Pentagon Mission
approached the Panic Room dear Schaefer
and many have been hiding out
she ever needs to be returned to his bed
and while on their way many and Kelso
discuss how the black task was able to
take down the network
many acknowledges that he overheards on
saying that the countermeasures worked
perfectly
they know that Shaffer was the target
but as long as they have the mobile shd
server well Limited in range their
skills and comms are working
the next step is to get the White House
defenses back online and find out
whether this shd network blackout is
just local or is in fact a global
shutdown
I'm impressed
credit where credit is due
you and your little team of Misfits
managed to decrypt my calms
you passed the test Manny you really do
have an eye for talent
first Schaefer then Lewis and Wally
imagine my surprise when I discovered
you even managed to recruit Vic I
thought you hated him after what
happened at odia
but here you are welcoming old enemies
into your house and giving them the
literal keys to the castle I haven't
decided if you're a genius with
boundless empathy or a [__] who
actually believes that people can change
people don't change
most of the time
if you think someone has changed
because you never really saw them you
never look close enough to see if the
person's staring back at you is genuine
or is hiding their true intentions
that's why you're so easy to fool and
why I will always be two steps ahead of
you
I have the Black Tusk the real true sons
and the hunters at my disposal
while your agents have civilians chasing
water bottles
by the way
thank you for sending your agents all
the way to Coney Island to check on
stovepipe
it's too bad you couldn't recruit him
too
but he forgot his place in my
organization and I do not tolerate
disrespect since you may be a [__] I'm
going to make my intentions very clear
this city
this country
this world belongs to us
we will take what is rightfully ours and
there is nothing you can do to stop us
isn't that right Vic
unit
what did you do with Mari and Cindy
don't worry Vic I wouldn't hurt them
they're too valuable to the future of my
operation it's not every day you find a
woman who can build and operate a fish
farm
she really is quite the catch Manny when
you're ready to surrender I would be
more than happy to reunite you two
lovebirds I hear stress can do terrible
things to a pregnancy especially in
older women Manny
if you really do love her
you might want to hurry
oh an agent
I hope to see you soon
this single long condescending comms
pretty much explains everything all
until we've been receiving throughout
this Manhunt has been compromised
this whole time everything we've been
listening to has led us to the setup to
have us removed from the equation so
that the black task can sweep in and
clean out the White House while mummy
and daddy weren't home
it's unlikely that Natalia had anything
to do with the dirty bomb attacks in St
Louis it was just the easiest way of
getting your attention
but it isn't to say that all references
to the recruited novel were just there
disc garrisoned moving out
but I'll get into that a little more
soon
Natalia has also confirmed that she has
Vikram Malik a name that we briefly
heard about earlier on after he betrayed
us at the odia tech building
as well as Mari Singh someone we
suspected would have a larger part to
play after several Khan's messages this
season alone
she not only leads the team at the
central aquarium one of DC's only
sustainable food sources but she is
pregnant with Manny's child
we're gonna have to be careful with any
Direction coming from him after the loss
of his friend and now this is going to
be a mess
but there was one other name that
Natalia mentioned a name I didn't
recognize
Cindy
I'm not gonna lie this is the person
Natalia took I hadn't really paid much
attention up until now
based in the White House Cindy is a
drone operator that has been involved in
scouting and alerting agents to numerous
threats in DC
it was also her drone that worked the
coordinated gtf and shd work on Coney
Island when extracting Vitale trinenko
as well as the Drone that was hacked by
Aaron Kina before he escaped
I'm not overly sure what Natalia is
hoping to gain from Cindy but I'm sure
we'll be finding out soon
on the way into the White House Black
task operatives can be heard saying the
countermeasure is still active and while
many is willing Schaefer out of the
Panic Room he says I overheard someone
say the countermeasures worked perfectly
given all of the references to the
recruited novel this season I feel that
it's pretty safe to say that this is
another reference to Thomas parrott's
work
in the novel The countermeasure is the
program Myra used to neutralize the
Rogue Network and Tech at the Kansas
core
this essentially keeps the call from
being destroyed by deactivating the EMP
fail-safes
Natalia's obviously managed to recover
Myra's code and has used it to shut down
the network and attack the White House
so my question how did Natalia get a
hold of this I don't recall anything in
compromised although I'm not going to
read it for the fourth time just to
confirm this
this will probably be one of those
things about Thomas Parrott and Lauren
Stone about over the coming weeks
I've actually held back on fully talking
about the novels out of respect for the
author and spoilers Etc but now that
we've reached the end of the first novel
in game maybe it's time I have a run
through
a fantastic ending to season 11 and year
four
there are a number of things that we're
left wondering about like the perfusion
bioreactor agent Sanders Cindy
McAllister Mari Singh Vikram Malik and
not to mention that we haven't heard
much from Kelvin McManus for a while
the year 5 roadmap has already been
announced yeah the naming conventions
have changed so I'm going to need to
change all the titles on these videos or
it will become very confusing Anyway
season 1 shows us that we'll be focusing
on Mari Singh and the aquarium with an
update on what happened with Aaron
Keener in season three
people seem to really like these
compilation videos and I get it I fall
asleep listening to documentaries Etc
the longer and more monotone the better
I don't care how you're watching my
videos I'm sure you're absorbing some of
the info in your sleep
maybe I should make a compilation of the
compilation videos into a sort of super
compilation that would be like four and
a half hours long on just the story
across seasons one to eleven
anyway as always I very much appreciate
your viewership especially if you manage
to make it this far once again a big
thank you to those who are able to go
the extra mile and support the channel
through patreon or YouTube memberships
I keep getting asked about a Discord
page and yes I used to have one in the
past but it got very challenging to
maintain as the numbers started getting
up there
but what about a smaller more personal
one for the patrons and members
just a thought at the stage but let me
know
thanks again and I'll catch you soon in
the next one
extremist malice extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]